ja es sind noch elf tage bis zu us wahl
dann entscheidet sich ja wer der neue
präsident in den usa wird vergangene
nacht unserer zeit lieferten sich donald
trump und herausforderer joe biden eine
letzte tv schlacht im großen und ganzen
ging es diesmal gesittet dazu das lag
aber auch am stumpf schall knopf für die
mikros also ständiges rein quatschen
waren nicht mehr möglich aber jetzt
zoffen sich die demokraten untereinander
es geht um diese aussage hier von joe
biden und es geht ums öl systemen für
die industrie
ob sie dies tun ich verstehe ja
ausgerechnet so kurz vor der wahl gibt
es jetzt also sogar zoff untereinander
unter den demokraten
ja die demokratische politikerin im
repräsentantenhaus tor small twitterte
umgehend ich widerspreche dem heutigen
statement von vizepräsident biden die
energie sei das rückgrat der wirtschaft
in new mexico man dürfe eine einzige
industrie nicht dämonisiert
ihre parteikollegin im
repräsentantenhaus kenji horn aus obama
stimmte ihr zu und sagte wir müssen für
die öl und gasindustrie aufstehen
ja und was das jetzt für den wahlkampf
bedeutet darüber möchte ich jetzt mit
bild chefreporter maximilian kieffer
sprechen ist für uns in den usa hallo
maximieren sondern sagen kann
frankreich an genau also was man sagen
kann ist das was wir da gestern gesehen
haben war eigentlich etwas was die
us-medien hier schildern als ein
boxkampf zwischen zwei jahre gleich
starken kontrahenten beide konnten
treffer landen und dann ganz am ende
eigentlich bevor die letzte fragerunde
kam da gelang dann kommt dieser eine
treffer denn er hat auch beiden konkret
darauf angesprochen und biden sprach
dann über das öl und wir haben es gerade
gesehen du hast es angesprochen
biden will weg vom öl und das ist
natürlich etwas was hier in den usa die
leute aufhören lässt es gibt wahnsinnig
viele jobs team mit öl zusammenhängen
das ist eine wichtige branche
und wenn plötzlich einer der kandidaten
so kurz vor der wahl erklärt dass er weg
will dann hören die leute da genau hin
und fragen sich was hat das für
konsequenzen für mich würdest du denn
sagen dass diese aussage jetzt die wahl
vielleicht sogar entscheiden kann
[Musik]
die isch kandidiere offiziell für das
amt des us präsidenten
die medien waren geschlossen gegen da
hat er sich mit hilfe von twitter seinen
weg geebnet damit sherlock holmes sagt
uns was er denke da weiß man was man hat
und das bedeutet bei einer
führungsperson sind eine bedrohung für
die demokratie
ich spreche aus was wir brauchen und was
es ist ein einreiseverbot
auch wenn man ein öffentliches amt
bekleidet darf man sich noch verteidigt
robert de niro ein individuum ic
niedrige weko hat in den filmen von
echten boxern zuviel schläge gegen den
kopf abgekriegt
das ist klasse er ist definitiv der
lustigste präsidentin der je hat so
davon als führer der freien welt nicht
daher rät und ich glaube er hat kein
frühstadium von widmen ist sondern vom
faschismus anthonys karachi ist ein
völlig labiler spenden meryl streep eine
wärmsten überschätzten schauspielerin in
meinen augen hat er eine neue form der
kommunikation davon
die letzte echte präsidiale erfindung
sachen kommunikation waren wo die
kamingespräche von rosberg
das sind alles dinge die wir in den
nächsten tagen sehen werden aber ich
glaube im unmittelbaren augenblick war
noch gar nicht so klar was beiden da
eigentlich gesagt hat aber in den
stunden danach du hast die tweets gerade
gezeigt da haben dann die demokraten
selbst erkannt was das ja für einen
verein sprengstoff eigentlich ist was
daraus werden kann
gerade in den wichtigen swing states für
diese wahl wo besonders viele menschen
von der ölbranche profitieren und
arbeiten und man muss dazu auch wissen
die ölbranche ist jetzt schon
angeschossen in der korona phase haben
millionen menschen schon jetzt ihren job
verloren die öl förderquellen in den usa
liegen zum großteil brach warum weil die
leute nicht mehr so viel auto fahren die
leute sind im home office also da ist
sprengstoff und da wird man sicherlich
in den nächsten tagen genau hingucken
müssen und mag sie wollen auch einmal
auf eine politische stimme schauen aus
deutschland lars klingbeil hat sich
heute dazu im gespräch mit teilweise
meinem kollegen geäußert kostet ihn das
den wahlsieg dieselöl aussage von joe
biden nein das glaube ich nicht wenn man
sich auch pitts gerade schon ausholender
welche art of cnn
doch noch mal ältere aussagen gesehen
noch von beiden zur frage der
energiepolitik muss um fracking gegend
wo es viel differenzierter war
ich glaube da kann er einiges
klarstellen aber dieser kurze moment da
würde ich darauf wetten der wird von den
amerika von den republik einem netz
hochgezogen ja soweit also die aussage
von lars klingbeil spd generalsekretär
der maximieren wie sind aktuell die
umfragewerte in den usa wer nicht vorne
also landesweit und in den wichtigen
sting swing states da liegt ganz klar
die beiden vorne und was interessant ist
was uns auch alle leute hier sagen es
gibt eigentlich keine bewegung in den
umfragen seit wochen liegen beide
parallel ist gelingt trump einfach nicht
ja das ruder rumzureißen näher
heranzukommen an beiden es sind wichtige
staaten in gefahr aus der sicht von
donald trumps staaten die er vor vier
jahren ja teilweise überraschend
gewinnen konnte
und natürlich war die hoffnung auf
seiten der republikaner dass sich beiden
in der tv-debatte ein aussetzer leisten
könnte dass man das nutzen kann um das
ruder rumzureißen
ob das diese aussage am ende sein kann
wird sich zeigen
momentan sieht es aber eigentlich eher
nicht so aus wir wollen noch einmal
inhaltlich auf die tv-debatte schauen es
ging ja auch vor allem ungeheuer wollen
wir einmal noch mal reinschauen ein
ausschnitt den zeigen wir ihnen gleich
ich kannte das schon mal zusammenfassen
group ist war natürlich wieder so dass
trump er hatte ja selbst corona ist
mittlerweile wieder geheilt er spielt
die krankheit den virus runter sagt dass
99,9 prozent diese diesen virus diese
ansteckung quasi überleben würden und
beiden hingegen hält dagegen und sagt
das ist total gefährlich nein wir können
ich mit der krankheit leben wir werden
mit ihr sterben
was ist deine einschätzung dazu wer hat
da punkte gemacht also das ist eine
kultur debatte hier in den usa auf der
einen seite ja die wissenschaft die die
die forderung die masken zu tragen und
auf der anderen seite dieses
freiheitsliebende amerika zu sagen wir
können und wollen uns nicht einschließen
trump hatte gestern auch ganz persönlich
gemacht er hat gesagt ja beide ganz
amerika kann sich nicht wie du wochen
lang im keller aus einschließen und
nicht raus kommen sondern wir müssen
rausgehen wir müssen arbeiten und das
ist hier eine eine debatte die ja durch
familien läuft über die staatengrenzen
läuft und wo sich zeigen wird welchen
weg amerika am ende einschlagen wird
fakt sind zwei dinge erstens die zahl in
die korona infektionszahlen die steigen
dramatisch wieder an
in amerika sind schon 200.000 menschen
gestorben und vorhersagen eigentlich von
allen aus allen lagern von allen
wissenschaftlern sagen vorher dass noch
mal so viele also noch mal 200.000
menschen sterben werden das ist das
womit er nicht wieder dann der weitere
präsident donald trump oder der neue
präsident joe biden arbeiten und umgehen
muss insgesamt lief die ganze debatte
ein bisschen friedlicher ab aber es gab
auch ein paar reibereien und da wollen
wir jetzt einmal reinhören
im vergleich zur ersten tv debatte war
das ja relativ harmlos wie kann das
jetzt in den usa an dass es doch
gesittet zuging sehr sehr gut und das
war auch etwas was eigentlich das
gesamte trump lager von ihrem
präsidenten gefordert hat weniger ins
wort fein weniger aggressiv sein
das kam nicht gut an einmal kam es nicht
gut an gerade bei den weiblichen wählern
von trump da liegt schon finden da muss
er boden gut machen
und eigentlich alle trump wähler warten
darauf haben darauf gewartet dass beiden
sich einen dieser bekannten aussetzer
leistet und der so war die hoffnung
zumindest würde erst dann kommen wenn
man beiden aussprechen lässt wenn man
ihm nicht immer gleich ins wort fällt
diese strategie war gestern bei jump auf
jeden fall zu sehen er hat ihn ausreden
lassen er war höflich am beide haben
beide kandidaten haben auch
zwischendurch die moderatoren gelobt
also das war auf jeden fall sehr viel
gesitteter und ich würde auch sagen
deutlich auch sehr viel inhaltlicher was
wir da gestern zu hören bekommen haben
ja und auf twitter wurde dann im
nachhinein aber doch noch mal ausgeteilt
diesmal von joe biden da wollen wir
einmal kurz auf den schritt schauen
er sagt über trump er ist ein verwirrter
typ er weiß nicht gegen wen er antritt
er tritt gegen joe biden an und weiter
donald trump ist der rassistischen
präsidentin der modernen geschichte ja
wie ist deine einschätzung dazu max ist
das schon unter der gürtellinie ist das
noch normaler wahlkampf das ist die us
wahlkampf und das ist vor allem usa
donald trump in diesem system angekommen
ist und ja dieses system nutzt wir haben
einen us präsidenten der seit vier
jahren mit twitter kann man sagen
eigentlich regiert am außenpolitik macht
in politik macht leute beleidigt
zuspitzt und insofern glaube ich ist das
etwas woran sich zumindest die leute in
amerika gewöhnt haben und was
mittlerweile auch einfach dazugehört
dankeschön maximilian b chefreporter
live aus arizona aus den usa vielen dank
wir haben es gerade noch mal von
maximieren gehört trampe liegt also weit
hinter joe biden seinem herausforderer
und deswegen muss jetzt familie
unterstützung vonseiten schwamm her
damit er vielleicht noch aufholen kann
gerade bei den frauen ivanka trump soll
das schaffen
donald trump league gegen rivalen joe
biden in den landesweiten umfragen
deutlich hinten allerdings liegen beide
in möglicherweise wahlentscheidenden
bundesstaaten nahe beieinander
die tramps machen mobil zur
schlussoffensive
wie hier tochter ivanka trump im
kalifornischen fort myers die groß
gewachsene beraterin im weißen haus
betritt unter frenetischen applaus
einiger hundert anhänger das podium am
pop rock a field war im harley davidson
händler
viele der in einer wiese aufgestellten
sessel bleiben aber leer die anhänger
stört das wenig in ihrer rede neben
einer riesigen us flagge preis ziehe die
errungenschaften der tram wäre an
darunter die angeblich großartigste
wirtschaft in der geschichte der
menschheit und genau das wollen die fans
auch hören er ist wie kein bisheriger
präsident er sagt einfach die wahrheit
er sagt einem nichts was man hören
möchte er ist kein ja sager
er sagt es genau so wie es ist und man
muss sich nie fragen woher es kommt bei
visionen oder players trump in seiner
zweiten amtszeit eigentlich noch so
vorhabe bleibt tochter ivanka trump eher
vage hart sind ihre attacken auf
konkurrent joe biden der würde das land
gegen korona wieder zusperren und den
amerikanern billion dollar an
zusätzlichen steuern abknöpfen
die rolle von james ältester tochter im
west wing des weißen hauses war schon
immer umstritten
auch nach fast vier jahren amtszeit
scheint unklar was genau sie tut
im wahlkampf soll sie vor allem an der
frauen front für mehr stimmen sorgen wir
sind bild und wir liefern dir deine news
auf youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren